what's going on guys this is Rob and
with Marvel's Gods event coming out here
in the next few months I thought it'd be
cool to make a series of videos
explaining the Multiverse and Marvel
Comics and in this video we're going to
explain what's called the celestial holy
war and the birth of the first
Multiverse now one thing that I do want
to specify here at the outset is that
each iteration of the Multiverse is
sentient meaning it is a conscious
living organism we'll go more in depth
into that as we get into the video that
covers the histories of the different
versions of the Multiverse that have
existed in Marvel Comics but for the
here and now and as part of this
discussion all we really know is that at
the beginning of everything there was
What's called the first firmament also
known as the first Cosmos or the first
Universe you will see those terms used
interchangeably in Marvel Comics but
while we don't know exactly who created
it we can largely assume it was the one
above all but again we're not given a
definitive answer now all this is
covered in alguing's ultimates and what
he tells us is that at when the first
firmament came into existence it was
both lonely but also full of arrogance
because of how much power it had and
what it did is it created a group of
beings called the aspirants not aspirins
aspirants and so these things these
organisms were astronomically powerful
in terms of what they could do so much
so that they started traveling around
the first firmament and they started
creating galaxies and solar systems and
stars planets life different things like
that now what would happen is that every
time the aspirins created anything they
would present it to the first firmament
and seek its approval if the first
firmament was satisfied they would be
allowed to continue on with their
creation if the first firmament was
dissatisfied they would destroy their
creation and they would start over again
now the whole kicker behind all this is
that these things that were created
would effectively live for eternity so
if we assume for example they created
Earth and they put human beings on Earth
they would only put a finite number of
human beings say maybe one billion and
those 1 billion humans would live
forever not only that they would live
unchanging meaning they would never age
they would never die none of that stuff
right they would stay stagnant for all
eternity now this whole thing also
extended to like galaxies and stars and
so on they would be in that shape
perpetually forever the problem with
this is that some aspirants believed
that was a problem that life should
experience growth change mortality and
even death so galaxies should die Stars
should die Planet should die and so too
should sentient life and even the first
universe itself should die and that
eventually be reborn into something else
and so because they held this differing
ideology they effectively split off from
the aspirants and started creating life
and things of their own design without
seeking the first prominence approval
what they also did is they changed their
physical form instead of being
monochrome which is to say black and
white in this instance they made
themselves multi-colored then they
changed their names and started calling
themselves celestials so that's where
you get celestials from and Marvel
Comics pretty cool origin story huh now
the thing behind this is that because
they were considered Heretics by the
first firmament what ended up happening
here is the first firm in itself branded
them as Traders and a war broke out
between the aspirants and the celestials
now something to grasp here is this is
like a giant Civil War among beings each
one of which is as powerful as a
Celestial so imagine a war among beings
that's capable of creating entire
galaxies and solar systems you can
imagine how astronomically dangerous
that kind of War would be and the
consequence of it is exactly what you
would think it would be we don't
definitely know exactly how it played
out the only information that we really
get is that this war was prolonged for a
lengthy period of time there was really
kind of a stalemate going on but the
celestials had developed something
called the god killer armor now that was
actually introduced in Kieran gillen's
run on Iron Man and a story called The
Secret origin of Tony Stark it's really
really cool but the thing about this is
that while the celestials were creating
the god killer armor the aspirins for
reasons that were never explained to us
fell into a state of Civil War and so
what that did is it decreased their
numbers by a pretty huge margin again
we're not given any definitive numbers
here but we're told that like it
basically shrinked their ranks by a
pretty good chunk and so in the Fallout
of this Civil War and with the aspirins
already weakened the celestials fired
off their God killer armor and basically
shattered the first firmament into an
infinite number of pieces and that gave
us the first Multiverse now one of the
things that did happen here which we're
not really going to go into a whole lot
of detail about is that the first
firmament the essence of it along with
the aspirins took off to a place called
The far Shore now the reason why we're
not going to talk about that too much
and we can kind of talk about the far
Shore here that's because the far Shore
is not really part of the Multiverse per
se it's really beyond the Multiverse and
anything that could be considered the
Multiverse the far Shore is largely
presumed to be the realm of the one
above all that's where really Godly
beings or Cosmic entities go to die now
there is also the god Quarry and we'll
talk about that in a future video as
well but the far Shore is a pretty cool
concept it's a pretty cool idea you
don't see it often in Marvel Comics but
it is cool when it does appear having
said that with the first Multiverse
being created from the pieces of the
first universe's physical form the
celestials in turn did two things the
first thing they did is they created
what were called the omegas now that's
the name that was originally given to
them in Marvel Comics and More recently
in Al Ewing's Defenders beyond that name
was changed and we'll talk about what
that is here in a second but the omegas
were charged with basically ensuring
that a war never broke out between
between the celestials again and that if
a war like that happened the omegas
would have enough power to eradicate all
celestials involved blink out and wipe
out all of creation and then effectively
start over again and so what this did is
it led to the Omega as being placed by
the celestials in a location that's
technically outside the Multiverse but
basically monitors the Multiverse from
the outside they of course ended up
becoming the beyonders and they are
basically in What's called the Beyond
verse now again alewing changed all that
stuff from the way it was originally
done now that of course was again
covered in Al Ewing's Defenders Beyond
and we're better for it because prior to
that story we never really got any
meaningful explanation about the Beyond
verse or the beyonders or where they
came from so it's a pretty cool little
tidbit there the second thing the
celestials did is they duplicated
themselves as an infinite number and
placed a different version of themselves
throughout the Multiverse that's why
every Universe has a version of a
celestial like ayersham the judge right
or the collector or the gardener or
something along those lines now having
said all of that if you guys want to
understand or get caught up on Al
Ewing's ultimates and Defenders Beyond
make sure you guys click the link to
this playlist you guys are gonna
absolutely love that story thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later
peace